hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's the 9th of April and you're
watching gamespot news here's all the
things that matter square-enix have
already had a pretty busy week
announcing Deus Ex mankind divided but
now it seems they're ready to tease
another secret project Jill shockers
have discovered that square enix
launched a website which admittedly
seems pretty basic upon a first glance
jpg Square hyphen Enix calm forward
slash secret will take you to a landing
page featuring a background that seems
to be water or clouds above the earth
there's some contention as to which in
the foreground other loaders SAR and the
numbers 0101 presumably these will fill
out to reveal the project's name if you
opt to click a social media share button
it's revealed that the project will be
announced on Monday April 13 so check
back with me then there's still a week's
wait until GTA 5 hits PC but Rockstar
have today revealed the game's extensive
graphics and PC control options GTA 5
for PC has both a graphics tab and an
advanced graphics tab these will let you
do everything from adjusting the overall
resolution and aspect ratio to altering
the quality of shadows reflection water
and grass you can adjust the motion blur
strength using a slider as well as the
population density and subsequently
population variety the game will also
allow you to customize key bindings and
the just a few different kinds of mouse
sensitivity within the keyboard and
mouse settings finally if you haven't
had enough of vague black ops 3 teaser
videos do I have the story for you
thankfully it's a big step up from the
ten-second weird snapchat video from a
couple of days ago well maybe a baby
step the minute long video includes a
whole mess of voices and references to
alex mason who featured in black ops 2
we're told that activision will reveal
the full game on
sunday april 26 the video entitled back
in black also depicts a not-so-subtle 3
symbol which would seem to quash any
theories that activision aren't teasing
black ops 3 let me know down in the
comments what project you'd like to c
square enix announced come Monday and
why you can add against what we've got
news on Google Play blocking a postal
port and Daniel Radcliffe's potential
GTA project that is all the good stuff
that I have for you today do you
remember that tomorrow I'll have the top
five stories of the whole gaming week
ready to go so be sure you check back
with me then